[Music]
everybody welcome to the podcast we're
back with another ask me anything I
think we're calling this series roll on
yeah Adam rolling it episode 2 of roll
on I'm back with my buddy Adam Adam
Skolnick writer journalist activist
author co-author of can't hurt me
the epic David Goggins memoir probably
the most successful independently
published memoir ever it's gotta be
right I mean who knows I don't I don't
really know if there if there's a way to
quantify that but it's I mean Goggins as
those books have been selling really
well it's still selling like crazy isn't
it is it is it still doing well it's
been like top 20 on the amazon charts
for a year and a half now that's insane
yeah what a crazy ride that's been for
you yeah I mean for most yes it's been
crazy it's been it's uh you know when I
first started working with David and the
opportunity arose I kind of figured it
would be a great way to help some people
but I don't think you could ever have
imagined I mean I didn't imagine yeah it
would be to this level and to have him
self-published and do it all the way he
wanted to do it on his terms and to
reach this level is it's got to be close
to unprecedented if it's not
unprecedented
is he and you working on a new book not
at the moment no I mean he he is he is
he's he is working on stuff but we'll
see how it all manifests I mean he's
always working on stuff so right oh he's
coming up with here the post he just put
out I was amazing I don't know if you
saw I haven't seen the latest one that
they're super inspiration yeah yeah and
this one is a kid like so crazy views
too he follows nobody and what does he
have like two million people yeah
Instagram maybe
maybe more I can't remember what what it
is now it's not believable and for the
two or three people listening or
watching who are not familiar with that
book definitely pick it up and I would
highly suggest the audiobook which Adam
reads and then after every chapter you
guys do kind of an informal podcast
breakdown yeah version of that chapter
were you and David interact yeah and
that was you know that was all David's
idea invited me to read it and then but
that really came out of the
collaboration you know I was lucky
because for me I had like it was
basically David Goggins on Broadway like
one-man show for three months where I
would just talk to him and he would just
go off on these incredible I mean he's
such a master of his own story right and
the first time I ever heard of him was
on your podcast and and he did that on
that and he's that's why such a great
podcast because he just goes right um
and so I got a chance to listen to that
and then and and so over the course of
that several months that we were working
together it became clear to him that it
was a great way of doing it would be
tonight for me to read it and then talk
about it together and so we were able to
drill down deeper into the stories that
people hadn't heard before so it ends up
being kind of a companion piece to the
print book right yeah well it's
incredibly impactful book okay so
congrats on that for those that are new
or missed our first edition of roll on
is where to call it that
what we're gonna do here the idea is
Adam and I are gonna have a loose
discussion kind of oriented around I
don't know just whatever's top of mind
and then drill down into listener
questions so we created a little bit of
an outline today and we've got some
questions that we're going to be
answering and the idea is that we're
going to make this a consistent series
on the show probably every every other
Thursday so the way that we've
traditionally published is a long-form
interviews go up every Monday and then
every other Thursday I've been putting
up episodes and the idea behind those
midweek episodes was to explore
opportunities to do something a little
bit different hence the guru mole
rehearse series and the coaches corner
and I think this is gonna find its place
you know in that kind of sphere so
that's the idea maybe we can start with
a little bit of feedback from our first
episode which was interesting I think it
was overwhelmingly positively received
although there was a little bit of
criticism oriented around the fact that
the first conversation that I've had on
the show regarding the protests civil
rights and black lives matter was
between me and and you know my my white
Jewish friend yes casting choice right
like I took some heat for that
understandably so and at the time my
thinking was well I've got all these
other you know episodes chamber
long-form conversations with with black
Americans African Americans people of
color and those are gonna be coming but
I think I should have put one of those
up before an hours and to contextualize
our conversation my thinking was well
this is a midweek episode everybody
knows those are a little bit different I
don't think anybody cares about that No
so to all of you who might have been
harboring that that feedback or that
notion I understand where you're coming
from yeah I mean and that's okay it's
okay to take that kind of heat you know
there's I think you were getting some
heat from people who are not coming from
a good place or from or even from a
legitimate gripe I'm okay with that yeah
and but it's even okay to get the good
this kind of chrism and this is this is
the lesson right we need to be open and
listening to our friends that when they
have legitimate grievances yes this is
what we've been talking about this is
the process right I mean podcasting is
very much an experiment in thinking out
loud in real time so I'm not going to
always get it right you know I'm
endeavoring to and I'm attempting to
learn and you know expand my horizons
and get out of my comfort zone to
grapple with these really important and
difficult
old issues but that doesn't mean that
you know I'm always gonna say the right
thing you know right so I'm aware of
that and I'm willing to take that risk
because this is so important so in many
ways this is a maturation of the show mm
stepping into something that's a little
bit you know askew from the typical
programming but I can't imagine not
doing this I mean what is the point of
having a platform if you're not going to
speak to the matters that are of most
urgency and importance to our culture
right now yeah I think and I mean isn't
that the point of this new endeavor roll
on is to be able to respond not only to
what's happening around us in real time
but also to respond to comments about
the show just be able to respond to your
listeners yeah and to address their
concerns your concerns in a kind of
formalized way yeah 100% and and to do
that we've had to shift our workflow a
little bit historically the program has
been set up where I record these
conversations and they may not come out
for four to eight weeks right which is
fine when you're talking about health
and fitness and nutrition which tend to
be relatively evergreen subjects but
right now that doesn't work anymore at
least it doesn't work to the extent that
I want to talk about what's actually
going on so we've moved things around a
little bit to try to be more nimble it's
not a daily show and it's not a news
program but I do want to be able to be
more contemporaneous with current events
and to be able to be more connected to
the audience and responsive to their
direct questions to me and to be able to
have an opportunity to share my thoughts
on matters of interest to them yeah
perfect you had some comments on on
sprouting on the Facebook group do
that's right so for those who don't know
we started a Facebook group for the
podcast
I think it's Facebook groups rich roll
podcast or rich world pot I'll put a
link up into the show notes to it and
it's been a really cool community the
idea there was to just create a place
for people to discuss the show and our
episodes like-minded people to
communicate with each other less about
me being involved in it I want it to be
its own thing independent of me
but I post there occasionally and I
check in when I can and in the wake of
the sprouting conversation with Doug
Evans the entire feed not the entire
feed but a lot of the posts are people
sharing their sprouting experiences
which has been really cool I shared it
with Doug the other day he was like
delighted fantastic and that myself I
ordered him after having Doug on the
show I ordered a bunch of sprouting
stuff online I got a bunch of containers
and some seeds
I think sprout man is where I got
everything that's what Doug suggested is
the best site to get this stuff and I
got a rack up in our kitchen and I've
got maybe seven canisters going right
now the different phases really and it's
been really cool what do you got well I
just got all the okay took a long time
with Cova to get everything in the mail
but now I think I'm on day three of my
first like harvest so these are about
done and ready to eat none of them have
spoiled yet and I got another rack below
that I just started last night different
ones yes brach I've got broccoli
broccoli sprouts lentil pea Doug gave me
a mixture that's like a protein mixture
that was like chickpeas and a bunch of
different stuff in it and I got a couple
others I can't remember but it's super
simple and it really doesn't cost
anything these these jars cost almost
nothing I mean you could do it with
mason jars if you want with cheesecloth
on top of them and I just have a simple
like dish drying rack where you angle
them at a 45 degree angle and it's right
next to the sink so every time I go into
the kitchen I'm reminded you know two or
three times a day to just rinse them out
and it's been fun man I it's so easy and
it like literally the seeds cost you
know like pennies did you have to like
lease a corner of Julie's kitchen to get
this to get this approved or did she
just immediately approve it normally
she's very proprietary about her
workspace in the kitchen but I think she
was so excited that I took an interest
in something culinary like it is the
great like myth about our marriage and
our work together you know we have all
these cookbooks and all of that but like
Julie is the chef like I just sit there
and you know watch
dishes HAFTER for you approve yeah I'm
not the culinary genius you know I mean
so the fact that I was like I want to do
this she's like wow that's cool she's
all excited yeah I bet anyway my kids
are like what is that salads like as a
main thing for a long time right like
like like yeah in the middle of the day
I've see I've had many I've had a few
lunches with you and it's always been
like a big salad first yeah typically
but I don't I'm not growing those that
produce in my yard no no no yeah so this
is a new thing for me yeah yeah very
exciting it's very cool
so what else we want to talk about we
want to talk about what happened in
Westlake yeah I think you should talk
about that I mean he sent me this thing
this morning yeah so justjust today news
broke about an incident in in my back
yard we're recording in Thousand Oaks
right now and in this neighborhood three
individuals got busted for defacing a
black lives matter sign one of whom
worked for the sheriff the other worked
for the DA and I think the other one was
a private citizen but and the DEA guy
was an assistant investigator right yeah
yeah yeah I mean the DA's office in the
sheriff's office did respond swiftly to
put these guys on leave but they're on
paid leave pending an investigation and
they were arrested right they were I
believe they were arrested yeah yeah
misdemeanor citations yeah and I guess
this the person who put this sign up
which is right on West Lake Boulevard
which is a heavily trafficked Road out
here
his sign had been two-faced a number of
times so he put up one of those ring
cameras and recorded the whole thing on
video fantastic so yeah man you know
this stuff is still going on it I think
it's I think it speaks to the you know
when people say there is no problem like
there is a problem you know the fact
that things like this are happening are
indicia that there is you know in
underbelly a dark underbelly of of
racist attitudes and behavior and this
is made manifest in this particular
instance
and you know what motivates that is it
is it you know some kind of repressed
white rage is it a sense of
disenfranchisement is it just patent
overt racism like I don't know these
individuals I don't know what motivated
them to do that the fact that somebody
could do that in this moment in 2020 is
upsetting in the own community is it
resentment because they feel like
there's now people hate cops because of
black lives matter or something I mean
maybe I mean one of these guys was it
worked in the DA's office not the police
department
yeah there's Sheriff so right you know
what I think two things one is further
evidence of prejudice embedded within
law enforcement which has been an
activation for a long time from people
of color and especially black Americans
and it has been given very little notice
until now you know we we hear it but
it's Essen hasn't sparked widespread
protest and in our lifetime until now
and and this is evidence of it this is
evidence in a place in Thousand Oaks
right in West Lake I mean this is which
is for people that don't know an upscale
suburban in Clary Way predominantly why
yeah yeah and that's and so and and just
the expression black lives matter has
driven these people to do this one of
whom is 60 years old right I mean he's a
60 year old man going out of his way to
deface something a 60 year old man
yeah it's similar to the guy in DC on
the bike yeah who was trying to rip the
the fliers out of the little girl's hand
all right
however that guy and it seems like a
lifetime ago it's like this morning of a
someone in their 60s like that trying to
get into a grocery store without a mask
and trying to barge past somebody do you
see that one and he falls and he's like
so furious like the fury of the 60 year
old white man I mean the only thing I
can think of this is a big problem that
we have in this country it's that we
have we have a country of adult children
right that have just not figured out how
to grow and be grownups
like like we wouldn't tolerate that kind
of behavior from children you know like
if it was a 13 year old going out and
vandalizing anything it would be a
problem in that family right if it was
like a 13 year old that wouldn't
wouldn't listen to the security guard at
a grocery store that 13-hour will be
reprimanded by his mom or his father
right then and there right when you
think about what is going on in the mind
of a 60 year old man that he's gonna
pull his car over driving down West Lake
Boulevard get out and and slash a black
lives matter sign yeah a six year old
man in maturity and the wrongheadedness
of that is unbelievable and it dovetails
perfectly with what we were who you're
talking about earlier both of us had
started listening to Greta tune Berg's
yes like sort of audiobook I guess
manifesto that she just released on
Spotify incredible I was listening to it
on the drive in and she just pulls no
punches mad you know what I mean and and
she speaks to this childishness of the
adults right she talks about being in
the congressional dining hall in
Washington DC where she's gonna have
lunch with all these congressmen and
she's looking around at all the fast
food outlets and it's Dunkin Donuts and
it's this and it's that she's like I see
these grown men and they're drinking
their pink milk shakes and eating candy
and she's like who are the adults yes
and these are the people creating policy
and it's like but there's so many places
we can go with that one is like she her
tone on the audio book is great like
like it's very clear she thinks we're
all a bunch of idiots right which we
probably are well she has a clarity
because she's not American right so she
comes to America and she sees it through
a different lens like there's there's a
distance between you know like because
we're so we can't see the forest for the
trees as we live here she doesn't have
that problem and when she's talking
about her road trip across America
it's very de Tocqueville oh yeah she's
got this you know laser view on all the
problems when she's driving through the
truck stops and she
seeing the oil refineries and the empty
parking lots in the 16-lane highways and
all of that and her ability to kind of
articulate the problematic nature of all
of this from a perspective of like how
did we get here like we're not even
beginning to address like all of these
problems you know she described she was
she was paraphrasing like making up fake
slogans for the states I was the license
plate under States and it was North
Carolina where even the salad bars don't
have vegetarian option I love North
Carolina now it's but but that but that
was pretty funny too Tocqueville you
gotta define de Tocqueville for people
that maybe don't know who he was so yeah
de Tocqueville wrote this book what's it
called on America yeah forget it was
like early 19th century so French guy
comes to America it's me on democracy
man yeah yeah yeah and he comes to
America and he because he's not American
he has this crystal-clear
objective perspective on the democratic
experiment yeah and help spread that to
France right enthusiasm across Europe
for it right yeah yeah yeah so we'll
link that up in the show notes meanwhile
a town in Siberia above the Arctic
Circle just exceeded a hundred degrees
Fahrenheit yeah yesterday or today yeah
I mean you know that I was I stopped for
gas on the way here and there's a
Starbucks connected to the gas station
or like on the same plot and I'm
listening to Greta and I'm thinking well
she's she is she is pissed off because
because she's she's appalled that so few
people are aware of this emergency
that's going on and the policymakers
like she has it out for the media the
policymakers basically everybody and and
I'm sitting there and as I'm pumping my
gas I'm thinking about pumping gas into
my car and watching 20 cars get in line
for Starbucks drinks probably in
disposable cups um with their engines
running in their conditions on because
it's a warm day here in Southern
California in the valley and she's right
to be pissed off you know like she is on
top of you know that's what is
interesting in the tone works in this in
this Spotify
project whatever it is because first of
all the riding is great she reads it
fantastic it's riveting right and the
tone just provides more urgency III love
it I think it's incredible and she's
right on she's still right on and we
still haven't quite woken up to it I'm
like you said like today nobody I mean
do people are people aware there's a
hundred degree days in Siberia
well CNN's were covering it it's there
they're reporting on it the impact of
that you know who knows right you know
it's it's kind of an astounding figure
though a hundred degrees Fahrenheit and
they're saying it's gonna be above in
Canada to right above the Arctic Circle
in Canada it's next that heat wave is
going to continue yeah yeah usually it's
60 degrees in June yeah yes I think 68
or something like that yeah one of the
other things Greta was talking about was
she visited a forest and was talking
with some Rangers there I can't remember
exactly who and there's been a
proliferation of this beetle that has
basically rendered 50 percent of the
trees you know destined to die which is
like this horrific thing that's
happening because typically the winners
are so cold and this but I think it was
in Canada that this beetle perishes in
the winter months yet because it's
warmer now the beetle is able to survive
the winter and continues to eat these
trees and so it's these these loops that
start to occur like this domino effect
that illustrates the tipping point that
we're facing right now it's feedback
loop after feedback loop and when those
change everything changes in the system
changes and what happens when these
systems break down and change sometimes
is things like viruses leaked into the
human food chain hmm and and and like so
there's a Manekshaw
intersection that's what we're learning
with race in America that's what we're
learning with science it's all
interconnected and everything becomes a
feedback loop right because we're all we
are like we were talking about earlier
we are like an organism on the planet
and functioning and so we're gonna be
everything comes back on you mm-hmm
and yeah yeah I think it's a good it's a
good place to pivot into food insecurity
and food injustice right yes another
you know kind of black mark on our
culture right now where we have these
pockets all across America that are
deprived of healthy food and healthy
options that are also economically
depressed and that creates its own
feedback loop that produces you know a
generation of people who are improperly
nourished and they're more susceptible
to chronic lifestyle illnesses their
brains don't develop as well their IQ
numbers go down there's all kinds of
statistics on this and this perpetuates
without any kind of you know
interference on our part out of system
level to redress this yeah I mean should
we should i define food deserts I went
on to the food empowerment project
website which is a great website a great
resource for this and so what I'm
reading now comes from them food deserts
can be described as geographic areas
where residents access to affordable
healthy food options especially fruits
and vegetables is restricted or
nonexistence it's non-existent due to
the absence of grocery stores within a
convenient traveling distance so there's
a report by Congress and the US
Department of Agriculture that 2.3
million people 2.2 percent of all US
households live more than a mile away
from a supermarket and do not own a car
now that is skewed because supermarkets
are defined very narrowly in these
reports and they can include stores
bodegas right like liquor store exactly
that have like a spare banana that isn't
even priced until the person goes there
and it can be a different price on a
given day and give it from a given
employee you know they're mostly most
commonly found like you said in black
and brown communities low-income areas
and so their their choices are limited
and it's also more expensive to get you
know it's what's known that fruits and
vegetables somehow are more expensive
than high fatty processed foods mm-hmm
and so when you're already low income
your choices you know so for a lot of
people wellness is a choice for some
people those choices are made for you
yeah it's a huge problem I had my friend
John Lewis and John Salley on the
podcast last week I'm putting that
episode up next that will be up on
Monday and one of the things that we
talked about in that in that column
sation is this very subject and those
guys in well mainly John John Louis I
think John Sally's on board as a
consulting producer but John Lewis aka
the badass vegan as he's known on
instagram partnered with Keegan [ __ ]
who's the the co-director behind what
the health and cowspiracy and they're
hard at work on this new documentary
that's now that they just retitled it
it's called
they're trying to kill us yep and they
showed me the trailer which should be
going public this week it might even be
today I'm not sure if it if it's public
by the time this podcast goes up I'll
link it up in the show notes but the
trailer is so powerful and it basically
takes a look at the disproportionate
impact of food and justice on
communities of color across the country
and the downstream impact of that on on
repressing their ability to improve
their lives and it's through the lens of
like hip-hop and music with all kinds of
interesting interviews with prominent
people from that community and the the
trailer is like insane I send it to you
right yeah yeah I mean it's I can't wait
for this but I wish the movie was coming
out right now cuz it would it would just
explode yeah so timely it's it's going
to explode because whenever whenever it
is because people are ready for these
kinds of this kinds of information you
know I think the there's there's more
and more plant-based people in the
african-american and people of color
community I think that's growing
athletes are the kind of the first
people in on it right and seeing the
performance and now it's just
flourishing as its own kind of
resistance its own like personal choice
the way to combat climate change
you know that's often I think you've
said it many times it's not the most
profound thing you can probably do to
help the planet right now on an
individual level well it's just one
thing that you could do every single day
three times a day every time you reach
for food yeah you're making a choice
yeah that has that kind of downstream
impact as a big impact I mean just a
couple statistics
between 1989 2005 so a little bit ago
the prices of fruits and vegetables went
up 75% in that same period processed fat
high fatty foods sugary foods the cost
went down 26% hmm
so sometimes these choices are made for
you right like we were saying and so
that speaks to the systemic nature of
all the systemic nature and so then when
you get we when those are the options
for you in order to make ends meet you
you drift towards those foods it seems
like it's cheaper but later you have
type-2 diabetes cardiovascular disease
other diet related conditions that will
impact your ability to make a living and
put you in the hospital or worse yeah I
mean when you're working two or more
jobs you've got some kids at home maybe
your single parent you don't have time
to cook the healthy options are not
geographically available they're perhaps
priced out of your range anyway yeah
what are you gonna do you're gonna go to
the drive-through or you're gonna hit up
the bodega you're gonna eat the process
stuff and you know that's the reality
for millions of Americans right now yeah
Jan over 2 million and you know Greta
talks about this also in her book like
the intersection of this with the
climate conversation she talks about the
fact that you can't talk about climate
justice without addressing social
justice like these are systems that are
inherently interlinked they are and I
think it comes back to something I you
know a couple of things I think you took
some heat for even getting into politics
now because for a long time like dealing
with evergreen issues it's not like you
avoided political conversations you you
like all sorts of interesting
intellectual discussions but I'm taking
on a political issue in the in real time
kind of ads potent tea to it yeah and so
you know but there is a connection
between politics and lifestyle choices
right I mean isn't there and and what's
the point of it like why do we make
these lifestyle choices do we make them
because they make us feel better do we
make them because they make us better in
all sorts of other ways like not just
feel better but stronger live longer
think clearer more clearly is it about
our own enlightenment or is there should
linked to a more a better way of living
in a communal level I think it should be
I think people act out of self-interest
yeah right so the entry ramp for anybody
is gonna be how do I feel better how do
I make sure that I don't get one of
these diseases how do I keep a trim
waistline how do I not die of a heart
attack like my father or my mother or my
grandfather those are the things I think
that motivate people the most and
probably the weight loss thing is that
you know that's the thing that you know
snagged people initially yeah because
talking about long term gains like hey
you know 25 years you're not going to
get diabetes and have your foot
amputated or you're not gonna suffer a
stroke like it's difficult to motivate
people based on things that might or
might not happen in the future right you
know if they're overweight then you can
get an immediate result by cleaning up
their diet but even trying to appeal to
the idea that they'll have more energy
that's difficult yeah so then to layer
on top of that like hey this is the
right thing to do for society I think
there's a select portion of the
population that will be motivated by
that but I don't know that that's going
to capture the fascination of the
average individual and I think that's
why this is such a difficult thing
especially when the processed food like
hits all the pleasure centers in your
brain when you eat it and it does create
this addictive response and it's
difficult to change habits and you know
it's hard to change and I'm sympathetic
to that it's hard to change on this
level and on the bigger issues in
America right now I mean lately so if
you can't get somebody to do it for
themselves how are you gonna convince
them that they should do it for the
planet and can use social engineer your
way out of these problems you know like
it's almost like from a one-level it
looks like these there's a deliberate
attempt to get people eat shitty food
but a lot of these things are it looks
that way but they're probably a million
decisions that went into this
profiteering yeah it's not like a mr.
Byrne sitting atop on some throne
somewhere making these nefarious
decisions to impact people in in an
inequitable way it's just
the tectonic plates of culture shift in
a certain way to business to create
these from you know lobbying you know
lobbying efforts on behalf of these
conglomerated food companies and the
farm subsidies and the way that campaign
finance works like all of these things
contribute to a system that produces
this kind of unhealthy result and
inequity and the only way forward is
twofold we have to deconstruct these
systems but we also and this speaks to
what what Dan Buettner talks about with
the Blue Zones we have to create
environments that are conducive to the
healthy choice if we're relying on
people to make their own individual
decisions when they're faced with a
panoply of choices it's not they're not
they're not gonna you know that's that's
not the way forward they're not gonna
make the right choice every time so we
have to create in environments where the
healthy choice is the convenient
affordable and you know easy to consume
option right from bike paths you know
healthy food that yes within arm's reach
and price effective based on the
community and that has to happen at the
that has to happen at the local
government level and at the federal
level at the state level at every level
like how is what we're subsidizing
because you're referring to subsidies of
I'm sure corn and soy but mostly corn
which becomes high fructose corn syrup
right and that ends up in products all
over the place
makes it super cheap yeah I had a guy
very very early on on the podcast he'd
be good to bring back on it's got David
Simon and he wrote a book called meat
anomic s-- that basically looks at the
subsidy structure in the animal
agriculture industry and basically the
the truth is if you stripped away all
the subsidies like the average Big Mac
would cost like you know I don't know I
can't remember the figure but it was
like a lot of money right it was way
more what does it cost now two bucks or
something right yeah it would be like
nine dollars or something that alone
would shift the landscape tremendously
yeah if you if you stopped subsidizing
the the food the cows eat and the cows
themselves would be too expensive deeds
much beef you wouldn't be able to have
fast food the whole the whole ecosystem
of fast food would shift as a result of
that amazing yeah I mean III did a story
for Sierra magazine in port country in
Eastern North Carolina and there what
has happened is that big conglomerates
like Smithfield Foods which is now owned
by a Chinese kind of multinational hmm
and most of that pork that's grown in
Eastern North Carolina ends up going to
China a lot of it right and so what's
happened is that the the individual
farmer that used to own the pigs and
sell them to the slaughterhouse or the
big company that distributed it they
don't own them anymore they basically
are paid a fee to grow the cat grow the
pig right and that fee doesn't cost
enough to treat the sewage so the sewage
ends up in these ponds then in the end
up getting flooded and just into rivers
sometimes they have to spray the spray
is sprayed on there rains down on the
local community which tends to be you
know mostly impoverished yeah you know
community yeah yeah and so but the the
kicker on that is that the actual pork
grower the the people that owned those
farms very few of them make any money
now I know so it ends up being doesn't
work for anybody really there are
they're essentially a modern-day
sharecropper yeah and they have to
procure so much debt to create these
farms and they become servants to that
debt and they can never transcend it
yeah and you know I've had many guests
on the show to talk about that I mean
that's another that's another instance
or example of the systemic nature of
this you have these conglomerated animal
agriculture companies that prey on these
farmers to you know basically convince
them to produce a higher level they need
to like though they'll give them these
loans and they're able to build these
you know industrial k foes yep but
they're always just shy of kind of being
able to be profitable beyond servicing
the debt right
some people can make it work because
they maybe own multiple K foes and so
they make it work that way the small
margin becomes something over over you
know if you can scatter it over six
different farms they bought but most
people suffer man most people can't make
a living
yeah I'm compassionate to those farmers
oh yeah we're trying to continue the
legacy of prior generations and this
beautiful tradition of farming yeah it
is part and parcel of Americana yeah I
mean that is a very different situation
right and and and when I was in Eastern
North Carolina this was in September or
October 2016 there was a trump rally
announced never tell you about this no I
don't think so and in the middle of
eastern North Carolina pork country they
dropped in like two with two days notice
he staged a rally and they canceled the
schools so that everyone could go to
this thing and I was there with some
community activists and environment and
the Riverkeeper
and we all heard this and all the local
people told me they'd never heard of
school being cancelled for any reason
other than like a weather reason schools
were canceled so that people could go to
this Trump rally him I went to this
Trump rally and but you see this
division that is sown because the people
who are trying to keep their lifestyle
going are victim to the Friends of Trump
but they are worshipping Trump or
grateful for Trump well that's the
disconnect right the idea that that this
administration it cares about them yeah
and their problem when in fact
everything that it's doing is at odds
with their personal self-interest and
that's what that's what the powerful of
you've been using race to perpetuate
that lie for hundreds of years hmm yeah
bringing back to that again which is
good because you can't escape it and
that's all yeah that's the air we
breathe right now well let's
why don't we pivot into some listener
email question let's do it so you want
me to fire him off yeah why not
okay cool well this is good because it
kind of plays right in
how do we move past our stories we're
dealing with a story now we'd like to
move past as a as a culture but also
individually this this one comes from
Derrick McMillan hi rich in your podcast
with James all teacher you both touched
on how we move past our stories rather
than continuing to be identified with
who we were
whether it be an addict criminal etc how
do you develop a positive relationship
with your past without identifying with
it in the present and letting it dictate
who you will be in the future Thanks
that's like the ultimate question it's
right yes yeah we all have these stories
that we tell ourselves about who we are
you know mine can be I'm an alcoholic or
I'm an athlete yours could be I'm a
journalist yeah so those are the labels
that we put you know there's
professional labels but there's also
these more at times insidious stories
that we quietly privately tell ourselves
about who we are and what we're capable
of I can do I can yeah I could never do
that you know yeah like yeah like well
Goggins can do that but I can't do that
right he's like that and I'm like this
right right
that's right I do it as much as anybody
I've done it historically over my whole
life and I think it's important to
understand that these stories are
illusion we fabricate them it's like our
brains want to make sense of ourselves
in our world and our past and our
capabilities it's like this mapping
device right and it's trying to identify
patterns there was a spiritual teacher
that I had many years ago and he
described it like buds on a branch like
if you take a tree branch and you see
the little buds where eventually
there'll be new branches right and we if
you look at that branch like a timeline
of your life we have a tendency as human
beings to identify these certain buds of
things that have happened in our past
and we weave them together to construct
a narrative right so it might be my
father abused me or you know I wasn't
able to get into college or you know
whatever it is right like there are
certain instances like events that
her and we hone in on those and we
create meaning around them and then we
weave them together but in truth our
life is made up of billions of decisions
and events that have occurred over the
course of our lifetime and we're myopic
to almost all of it except for these
little butts along the branch right and
we make this decision based on illusion
that these things are more meaningful
than everything else that's happened to
us and we construct an identity around
that and I think the process of learning
from that but not identifying with it is
one of self-inquiry I think it's a
lifetime journey of deconstructing that
and it begins with mindfulness because
the more that you can be present in your
life
the less you are the less you're
shackled to that past and that past as a
predictor of future behavior right so
the most tangible tactical advice I can
give to someone who's struggling with
this is to begin meditating and to try
to learn how to be more present in your
life I think these stories are important
to the extent that they can inform a
better path forward but detrimental to
the extent that we rely on them as
limiters and predictors of future
behavior your past doesn't dictate your
future but it will if you allow it to
and I think in most people's case that's
what happens you just say well because
I'm this way and this thing happened to
me that I can only do these things or
I'm not capable of doing these other
things and freedom comes with being in
the present and unshackling from that
narrative deconstructing it like really
being meaning well the more your present
the more your the more your wreath at
less reactive you are and the and the
less prone you are to just repeating
some cycle you know that's some deep
groove that's like in your brain about
how you behave because you're open to
what's coming at you verses ready to
defend against what's coming at you you
can you can evaluate your circumstances
more objectively rather
and reacting impulsively to them based
upon some prior prat like when this
happens I always do this right I'm not
even thinking I just do it this is how I
respond to these situations you know and
understanding that that's actually a
choice but in order to really embrace
the fact that you have options you need
to be present to create that little
buffer of time wherein you can reflect a
little bit more deeply on what's
happening so that the behavior that you
choose to then lean into is is coming
from a more reflective place as as as
opposed to a you know like an innate
response right and I think when you if
you if you do an inventory of your life
you know I would I would suggest people
start with what are those buds on your
branch like get out a notebook and write
down all of those things that you think
form your identity those those important
events in your life that you think are
formative and then I would challenge you
to then find other instances in your
life that that call into question the
veracity of whatever truth is that
you're hanging your hat on and I would
imagine that most people can find like
like you know I'm not I'm not worthy of
being hired for this kind of job because
I I've been fired three times in a row
well have you ever had a job where you
didn't get fired like try to try to put
truth to that lie in some regard and
understand that you have the power to
create a new narrative what you decide
to focus on becomes your reality so if
you can free yourself from being overly
focused on those buds along that branch
and those instances that create this
story you have the power to create a new
story for yourself what you decide to
focus on becomes your reality mm-hmm I
mean that's the that's the headline
right there right like our emotions
sometimes we feel like you know there's
there's right now especially there's
this idea of I mean I don't even mean in
in the context of the political
situation right now I just mean in this
generation and and with so many people
in therapy or whatever you hear people
saying well you know everyone wants to
express
feelings and their feelings become
almost sacred but not every emotion
needs to be right needs to be validated
right and not every emotion is valid um
it's it's you decide what emotions are
valid right and that's not to say that
if you've suffered a certain trauma that
you should pretend it didn't happen you
you know if that's the case that needs
to be looked at like seek out therapy
like unpack that what's behind that how
is it holding you back and and you know
start to develop tools to work through
that so that it no longer carries that
charge in that power that is inhibiting
you what would be an example of that for
you that where you had to move past a
certain story in your life maybe I mean
sobriety could be one but it was maybe
endurance sports what was it for you
that kind of like an example where you
constantly moved in a different
direction because you change story I
think I can give you two I mean one is
where I'm still kind of very much in a
story and one is where I'm actively
moving past a story and the first is is
you know addiction and alcoholism is
tricky right because I am an alcoholic
and I think there's certain people who
will tell you that they are they've
cured themselves of alcoholism or
they've transcended it and it's not for
me to judge that person's experience
maybe they have and if they have that's
fantastic but I I know that I have
alcoholism and that I need to treat it
and that treatment involves 12-step and
working with other alcoholics etc I have
a whole 12-step program for dealing with
this I will never like be cured of
alcoholism but that doesn't mean that
that that the fact that I'm an alcoholic
needs to define my entire life
experience it's something that I have
that I have to deal with and my first
priority as an alcoholic is to is to
help other alcoholics achieve sobriety
like I'm very unclear on that but that
doesn't mean that I'm like this single
issue person right you know I mean like
I do know people that are sober and that
are sober alcoholics and and basically
their entire
life is about you know talking about the
fact that they have alcoholism like
alcoholism is is something that almost
killed me and there's a whole story
behind that that I still hold on to I
don't allow it to identify Who I am but
it's a very powerful story in the sense
that it is a reminder that I as much as
I want to deny or ignore it that I have
a disease that would very much like me
dead hmm and then I have to remain
persistent in my recovery to abet that
internal urge inside of me that's doing
push-ups the minute I stop treating it
staying ahead of it right so that is a
story that that has truth to it
I don't overly identify with it but I
need to maintain the pertinence of that
story in my life in order to be well and
that's why when you go to like an a
meeting people get up to the podium and
they share what it was like what
happened and what it's like now and the
reason that they share what it was like
is a reminder to themselves as they're
sharing it and to everyone else like
this is where I came from like this is
why I do all these things now because I
would very much like to just forget that
I did all of those things and pretend it
didn't happen
yeah and it's important that I'm
reminded that that is you know
fundamentally who I was and who I could
return to being if I'm not vigilant so
that would be that one example of where
I maintain a connection to this story
for a healthy reason yep another example
would be this pivot that we're making
with the podcast right now it would be
very easy for me to just say well I'm an
I'm this endurance athlete and I'm a
vegan and I do a podcast about those
issues we're going to talk about
nutrition and how to be like an Ironman
triathlete or whatever and like stay in
your lane rich trust me I'm on the
receiving end of a lot of stay in your
lane comments these days which is weird
because your lane has always been pretty
wide there's a lot of people who who
would very much like me to go back to
that Lane and stay there anyone
triathlete putt that's a story that's
powerful like I could just stay in this
place of like oh I did five Iron Man's
on five Hawaiian island
tell that story again and again and
again and allow that to kind of dictate
how I communicate publicly yeah
I'm not that interested in that that was
a while ago like I'm in a different
place right now where you know I've
grown I still am an endurance athlete
and I love all that stuff but it's
important to evolve right and we're
trying to evolve the podcast a little
bit right now by doing what we're doing
right now and I don't want to allow that
story of who I was to dictate what I
have to be in the future that story is
powerful and I can leverage it as as a
way of reminding me that I'm capable of
putting anything I put my mind to yeah
because I've done some hard things I
know that I'm capable of more than that
other old story tells me which is that
you know you know I'm not good and I'm
an imposter syndrome I know there's
another question about that that we can
get into yeah so I use those stories for
the benefit that they can give me but I
don't try to I don't allow them to
hinder me from growth if that makes
sense yeah I think that answers this
question it totally makes sense I think
it does I'm you know the the idea that
we should be focused on not what we did
but where we're going know not where
we've been but where we're going but the
reason I think people love that story
also is because you know the story of
your ritual the endurance athlete is
because there's so many of your
listeners they they would like to get to
the point where they have kind of some
sort of physical mastery or getting
better and because it's interesting
would you be at the place you are now if
you hadn't gone through the crucible of
ultra which allowed to see yourself like
we talked to you talked about meditation
I don't know if you meditate daily or
not but comparing that to what you learn
about yourself in an ultra it must be
those are kind of they're not just buds
on the branch they're kind of their
formative experience yeah they're like
what do you like I'm spacing on the word
in India like a yoga
like where people come an ashram they're
kind of like the ashram of the mind in a
way yeah I mean I've always and I'm
happy to talk about all those things
because I want everybody to have their
version of that experience that I had
for myself because it was so formative
so endurance sports will always remain
you know a heart place on this show like
I love talking to endurance athletes and
exploring the teachings of that pursuit
right but I would also say that I got
into an endurance sports to learn more
about myself not to just become an
endurance athlete
it wasn't about podiums and winning
races and all of that and also wasn't
about you know being a competitive
athlete for the rest of my life like I
wanted to more deeply connect with who I
Who I am
so that I could be more authentic in my
expression of myself and as a result of
having that experience I learned a lot
about myself and I'm committed to
continually growing and evolving rather
than just doing this one thing staying
in my lane and you know pleasing a
certain number of people and because
what's the point if you're not going to
continue to get outside of your comfort
zone and challenge yourself and grow and
the point of pushing the comfort zone is
is to remind yourself or learn the
lesson over and over again that I can I
can be more than I thought I was right
and I can do I can I there's there's
more to me and that empowers the ability
to transcend those stories that hold you
back actually so it's like a feedback
right it's not yeah it's a positive
feedback it's a positive feedback loop
and and that plays into I don't know you
know Angela Davis legendary black
panther and an activist for you know
decades I saw a quote from her this week
and it was something like I I constantly
I can be an activist because I'm always
because I'm positive we are going to get
there I'm positive it's going to change
there is an optimism and optimism to it
knowing that it will happen mm-hmm and
and I think that there's a parallel here
as well moving past the store you can
move
past the story when you know there's
another place to go right and that
begins just to cap it off and we'll move
on to the next story like that begins
with mindfulness practices but it also I
would say a close cousin to that is
commit yourself to doing something that
that contravenes whatever that story is
even if it's a tiny small win mmm you
know create that little goal that would
put into question the veracity of
whatever story you're telling yourself
and with that small win you can then
build on it and ultimately you know
crater the sandcastle of that imaginary
story that you've been telling yourself
your whole life that's holding you back
I love that so make that goal and move
past it okay so there's a certain level
of being an open minded person to doing
all of that to staying open to some
other possibility so this comes from
Abbey Jenkins and kind of the bigger
question is when do you remain
open-minded and when do you stand your
ground and this is what Abby said I
struggle with the two contradicting
notions of remaining open-minded and
ever-growing versus standing up for
yourself with beliefs and opinions it's
hard for me to reconcile the two and I'd
love to know your thoughts on social
media I guess would life be simpler
without it I don't know I don't really
understand the end of it but I think the
real question is between those two
mindedness and stammers you're standing
your ground yeah I don't see them as
necessarily contradictory mm-hmm I think
if you're if you're first of all let's
start with open-mindedness yeah now more
than ever super important to be open
minded I think in order to be open
minded you have to have a healthy dose
of humility right yeah it means setting
aside whatever preconceived idea you
have about something so that you can
enter a conversation or read an article
or watch a documentary from a more
objective point of view to understand
that you know your worldview or whatever
it is you're holding on to is can be
challenged does require some humor
like we all like have our idea of what
the world is right and when that's
challenged can you get into a place of
openness rather than defensiveness mmm
and that's difficult you know it's very
difficult and right now when everything
is so heightened you know we're seeing
people clench down doubling down on
their worldview or their idea of what's
right and what's not right
so again humility is important for that
in order to be open-minded I think
reading is super important you know read
as much as you can from as many sources
as you possibly can
you can't have conviction about a
particular issue unless you're well-read
and well-versed on it yeah right
and I think standing up for yourself
with beliefs and opinions requires that
you have self-awareness self
understanding and conviction on a
certain idea or point of view right so
when you can confidently say that you've
educated yourself on something you've
checked in with your value system and
you think something is right then I
think it's totally appropriate to stand
up for what you believe in you can still
remain open to other ideas but that
doesn't mean that you shouldn't or are
not allowed to speak your mind
and your truth yeah does that make sense
I think it does
and by the way Abbi I have to apologize
I was i was reading the end of another
question no it is hard for me to
reconcile it too and I'd love to know
your thoughts on remaining open and
accepting yes well trying to also know
who you are and be confident in that I
would also say to that that if someone
disagrees with you to not take it
personally I think we personalize all
these things and then we become
emotionally charged yeah right because
we think somebody is judging us or
they're trying to deconstruct the
validity of our identity or something
like that when in truth somebody has a
different idea so can you it goes back
to mindfulness too can you remain calm
let's say you're in a conversation that
starts to get heated because it's two
opposing points of view you know can you
remain calm can you remain objective can
you receive what that person is saying
without it pushing
all your buttons and making you reactive
right okay then and then yeah can you
listen like we're if anything right now
we're experiencing a poverty of our
ability to listen right and I think with
the weaponization of social media and
the heightened you know emotional
climate that we're in with coronavirus
that's amplified by the social protests
and the unrest that we're seeing
everybody is on edge everybody's
shouting there's not a lot of listening
and honestly I fear for the you know
cohesion of our union unless we can find
a way to transcend this and as far as I
can tell the only way to do it is
through productive conversation we have
to be able to have grounded mature
productive conversations and we can't do
that unless we're able to listen and
unless we're able to receive somebody's
point of view that may differ from our
own and and and really take that in
mm-hmm and validate other people's
points of view exactly
we need our 60 year olds to be able to
see a BLM sign and not freak out yeah 19
if that 60 year old has a problem with
it there are other avenues for him to
voice you know exercise his First
Amendment right it's right I have no
problem with him doing that I may
disagree with him but can we move past
the emotional aspect of this so that the
conversation becomes more productive and
puts us on a path towards repairing past
damage and recreating you know a better
more healthy Union for everybody yeah
and being open minded isn't necessarily
a liberal thing or you know being open
minded and being open often people on
the far left are Jesse's up in my are
just close-minded this is not a partisan
thing no okay how do you deal with
impostor syndrome from Phillip Diddy you
have mentioned impostor syndrome a
couple of times in past podcasts I to
suffer or
from that despite some level of ability
to be successful in endeavors that I
feel an imposter in I'm grateful for
friends that mirror back to me my value
to them certainly you have recognized
that you have many fans and supporters
and even guess that you have had an
impact on it's a paradox for sure what
exactly does impostor syndrome look for
you how do you face and overcome it
enough to continue forward in your path
what would you tell someone trying to
flip the switch toward a desire to serve
humanity that is frayed of the next step
due to imposter syndrome yeah it's it's
a tough one because I'm always saying
that I suffer from impostor syndrome and
I think I do to some extent I had this
guy Chris Evans came to my house who
hosts the most popular morning radio
show in the UK on Virgin Virgin Radio UK
like the breakfast show he's a fan of
the podcast what's up Chris if you
listen to I love you and he's always
giving the show shoutouts on morning
radio and like London which is awesome
but he he he chant he came to my house
and we did a puppet we did our own
podcast for his show and he's like
you're always saying you're an Impala
you have imposter syndrome you don't
have imposter syndrome he's like you
know what you're doing I'm like a duel I
I don't know you know like I have to be
reminded and I think it's like a slow
boil thing like I I do feel like I can
own this space right now I've been doing
this for seven years I've interviewed
520 plus people
I'm confident when I sit here that I
know what I'm doing
that I'm gonna be able to get through an
hour and a half and it's gonna be you
know they're not all gonna be amazing
but hopefully you know all of them have
some value so that's a story that I have
to some extent transcended back to that
other question I like to throw it around
though every once in a while because I
you know I it is like we're it why do
you have those pinch-me moments where
I'm like what am i doing in Jack
Dorsey's house right now how did this
happen you know right do I have any
qualifications to talk to this guy like
or some you know incredible athlete that
I revere you know it's it's I think it's
more of a it's more of a humility at
this point
and Chase Jarvis photographer without on
the podcast who has a lot of wisdom on
the creative process says you know you
you you know you hear that phrase like
fake it till you make it he's like make
it till you make it just keep making it
you know like inch your way forward like
this podcast didn't start in this
beautiful set no no it you grow into
these things over time and with that I
think you slowly as you develop some
level of mastery over what you're doing
you're able to kind of transcend that
idea of being an imposter I would say
that I have a deep-seated insecurity in
me that is you know I've spent a
lifetime trying to unpack and overcome
but it crops his head up once in a while
and tells me like I have no business
being here and somebody else should be
sitting here and when are they gonna
when's the guy gonna walk in here and
take away my you know like sorry
who told you you're out who wants to
hear what you have to say or your
opinion on any of this you know the real
rich role is just down the Oliv the
imposter syndrome definitely is creeping
up around this new format because this
is new right it's like there are people
there are political pundits you know a
lot more about this stuff than I do
let's let them do that but I have to
make it until I make it right and the
more I can do that the less the less
like held hostage I am by that
insecurity in that sense that I am an
imposter so how do you drill that down
into some kind of tangible advice for
Philip it really is make it till you
make it right like if you're feeling
like you're an impostor don't give that
story power like act as if like acting
contravention a lot like do yeah take in
in in in a there's a phrase take
contrary action mmm-hmm so just because
your brain is telling you something
doesn't mean that it's true right your
instinct is broken often when it comes
to things like this so when you take the
contrary what would somebody who didn't
have impostor syndrome do well they
would make an
they're podcaster they would paint a
painting or they would like get up on
stage at the comedy store or whatever it
is right get out of your comfort zone
make it till you make it and take the
contrary action I like it to me I'm
thinking don't believe everything you
feel and write and but I think the
imposter syndrome there is a positive to
it not a not the syndrome but there's a
positive to the fact that you're not
comfortable there's something to be said
for not getting comfortable and knowing
that you have to show up and actually do
the work you can't just turn on the mics
and expect it to work you can't just
like show up and and put put take you
know get a story done have you haven't
done the research for the story yeah it
goes back to humility the the the
healthy second cousin of imposter
syndrome is humility
that's right psycho rather than say I
don't deserve to be here just say look I
have a lot to learn I'm still going to
show up get out of my comfort zone and
do this thing but I appreciate that I'm
just starting and I'm not going to be
perfect but I'm gonna do it anyway like
to have that courage to to do it in
perfectly right I felt like I felt like
I was an imposter for the first seven
years I was a journalist you know and
even even 10 13 years deep I still
wondered if I could do it right and and
I've been doing it for 13 years who's
gonna take that little hat off your head
with the press thing right right and now
now I don't feel that way anymore but I
still every time I have a new project to
do I still wonder can I do it but not in
a negative way I have this muscle
because you've done it so many times
like as a writer when you're beginning
that project you're like how am I ever
gonna figure out how to do this like it
just seems hopeless right but you've
been in that situation so many times
that you're like I know I feel this way
right now but I also know like I always
figure it out that's right it always
ends up better you know if you just do
enough drafts it'll get good yeah cool a
couple more how do you handle conflict
this is from Allison Warner how do you
handle conflict what advice do you have
for respecting the other person while
respecting yourself what about facing
and conquering the fear just before you
begin speaking
hmm so two questions what advice you
have for respecting the other person
while respecting yourself start there
respecting the other person while
respecting yourself I mean that that
goes a little that that dovetails a
little bit with the open-minded versus
stand your ground yep
question I think I would say with
respect to handling conflict
traditionally I haven't done this well
like this has been a huge learning curve
for me and and an instance in which the
tools of sobriety have been very helpful
to me
I am a notorious conflict averse person
I will do everything to avoid having to
deal with conflict and to this day I
still duck out of every uncomfortable
situation in which I'm gonna have to say
something uncommon oh that's difficult
so this is a battle that I've been
waging with myself forever and the
hilarious thing is that I used to be a
litigator right my job was to advocate
in conflict you know it's like probably
the worst worst professional you know a
situation for me to be in and I can
remember everyone or like you know
sitting in on deposition and just
thinking like can't you guys just get
over this like why can't we just make
this go away like I'm so uncomfortable
with the fact that there were parties
that were at odds with each other and I
just wanted it to be over with and to be
an effective lawyer you have to on some
level you have to thrive on conflict you
have to kind of maybe not enjoy it but
certainly be comfortable with it right
some people love it and I just remember
never feeling that way and that was a
big reason why I was like I just I can't
continue to do this for a living
mm-hmm at least as a litigator so I
guess what I'm saying is like this has
been a huge like mountain to climb for
myself and I think and part of that too
I should say comes out of what I think
is a somewhat laudable impulse or
instinct which is that I can always see
the grey and everything like no matter
what somebody's saying I can always I'm
pretty empathetic so I can always see
somebody else's point of view I think a
pretty good
at that and I think that that has been a
benefit to me as a podcast host because
to some extent I can I really try hard
to step into the shoes of the person
that I'm talking to but I think when
when you're able to see the gray and
everything it makes it more difficult to
erect healthy boundaries because you
defer to the other person's perspective
which is what I find myself doing so for
me handling conflicts in a healthy way
goes hand-in-hand with learning how to
create healthy boundaries for yourself
and understanding what those boundaries
are for you goes back again to the
process of self inquiry and really being
clear on what your values are like what
is okay and what is not okay
and when somebody transgresses you you
know crosses that boundary of what is
okay do you have the integrity and the
self-esteem to voice that boundary to
that person or a wreck that boundary or
move away from that person right when
you don't have healthy self-esteem you
don't you're unable to do that right
you'll let people steamroll over you
because you don't feel like your point
of view is valid or or has merit right
self-esteem comes through performing
esteem evil acts you have to do esteem
Abul things to develop that self esteem
the more self-esteem you have the better
position you're in to create that
healthy boundary and to make it be known
and I think when you're when you are
creating those boundaries or you have to
give voice to them it's also
understanding that it's not a personal
thing either it's like this is important
to me and I need you to respect that and
if that person has a person that you're
speaking to you has a problem with that
that's more about that person than you
because it's only somebody with low
self-esteem that that would be upset
that that person is upset with your
boundary right I mean well right these
are not the level it's not like you
either respect yourself or the other
person I mean ideally you're doing both
at the same time right we're juggling
here so you can like you can respect
yourself first you can't really respect
anybody else if you if you don't
but if somebody else doesn't respect a
boundary that you've created then
they're not respecting you and if you
allow them to do that that's a
reflection of your poor self-esteem
because you're not respecting yourself I
guess is what I'm saying
I think you've just terrified anybody
who just gave a lawyer or Taner
well hopefully the the lawyer they gave
the retainer to isn't someone like me
hopefully chose I was just able to do my
job relatively well you mastered it
yeah I did you were an imposter all
right this is a good one to close with
how do you discern truth from fiction
this is from Tom La Jones one of the
things I found hardest in the last few
weeks or months is how much false
information there's been thrown around I
personally have felt like I've lost
friends and teachers because they become
so engrossed in 5-g anti-vaccine cetera
conspiracy theories that it's tainted
all the lessons I've received from them
in the past which I also pass on as a
yoga teacher myself my question to you
or invitation for a topic of
conversation is how to discern truth
from non truth how to know who to listen
to and trust and why it even matters
perhaps if I simply turned the news off
and turned off my conspiracy theory
pushing friends on social media or just
turn that off altogether life would be
simpler this is a tough one life would
be simpler of course but I don't know
that it would be better and to the
extent that that Tom is questioning
whether or not truth matters let me be
very clear truth matters truth matters
more now than ever if we can't agree
upon what is true and what isn't true
how do we move forward as a society and
I think we're in a very precarious
moment right now where truth is being
questioned all over the place and the
firm ground upon which we stand in terms
of what is real and what isn't is
becoming more and more difficult to
discern and it's deeply concerning to me
truth is incredibly important
and I don't know how we got to this
place where we have become so
distrustful of vetted sources and so
prone to believing things from dubious
sources that it's made conversation back
to this issue of conversation very
difficult mmm right I don't know what
else to say other than that is incumbent
upon Tom myself you all of us to vet the
sources of our information to be more
mindful and conscientious about our
information silos and where we are
receiving information from we can be
open minded to go back to the other
question but we can't be we can't allow
ourselves to be susceptible to the level
of manipulation that we're seeing right
now and I think that vetting your
sources is important now that doesn't
mean that perhaps the New York Times
doesn't bend in a certain direction
politically but there is something to be
said for the journalistic ethic and the
standards of journalism that are
required to produce stories for
legitimate news outlet and outlets you
know you can receive those from
different points along the political
spectrum but I think when you're reading
blog posts and you don't know who wrote
this or where this information came from
or you're just digesting clickbait
headlines it's problematic so I don't
know what else to say other than that
you really need to vet your resource
your sources you know completely whether
it's podcasts newspapers television
programs news programs whatever mm-hmm
and and what about the when you see
people you respect start to trade in
these conspiracy theories or unproven
theories forget conspiracy but just
unproven theories
where does your mind go yeah I mean
first of all not all conspiracy theories
are untrue right many of them are so I
don't want it we're not going to debate
you know which one of these are true or
not right now but there are conspiracies
willing to say five g's is it true there
are there are there are some
conspiracies that you know it's like
that that that have validity so I think
when you're engaging with somebody like
that you could just say tell me more
about that you know allow them to you
know but you have to be convicted in
your own sense of reality I think to do
that yeah but you know you you don't
have to engage those people no you don't
you don't have to get into an argument
with them you don't have to follow them
on social media it's not your obligation
to prove them wrong no you have a choice
about what you consume so if this has
become problematic for you turn off the
television and get off social media and
go outdoors and enjoy your life and your
family and your children
life is short man no I think I think
what he's saying though the one thing
that is problematic with you know for a
long time this has been building this
direction there's a flattening of the
media landscape we're used to that you
used to be able to tell really quickly
what's a legitimate news source and what
isn't just by looking at it feeling the
newspaper or the magazine in your hands
now it's no longer our and now it's
harder to see
so there's flattening of that landscape
now for someone who works as a
journalist I always will trust the
journalists on the ground before I'll
trust almost anybody just because
they're there man just like I would
trust a doctor who's been through
medical school or through you know and
when it's an acute situation then I will
some guy right um but there has been
this desire and it's not just in in
journalism but there has been this
movement to attack the expert you're
right that's new that's new and what you
do is you love to bring in experts and
pro
experts and how to figure out what's
going on so for the betterment of your
listenership it's interesting that now
the expert whether it's a CDC guy or
whether you know whoever it is you know
whether it's found out if your effort
you're the first person to be dismissed
why should I trust you
you know an expert right you're an
expert why should I trust you it's very
strange a very bizarre where everything
is a little upside-down right now but I
think the reason it's not you know that
it matters is because now basically in a
real way our lives depend on it you know
like we can't have some people not we
can and we are some people are choosing
not to believe in it but the virus
numbers will go up so then I think one
answer to tom is just like you have to
stay awake yourself and realize that and
make choices knowing that you have to
put yourself in charge yeah I think and
take responsibility for your information
diet in a way that we didn't happy we
didn't used to have to know right no but
it is strange that now the first people
we call into question are the expert
yeah like how did we get to that point
and again it goes back to a breakdown in
our ability to basically be on the same
page about anything yeah and I think you
know part of the process of evaluating
your source material is is objectively
trying to understand like the the
motivations behind the piece right like
who stands to benefit from this what is
this person's point of view why are they
advocating for this in this way like if
you can read with a critical eye I think
that puts you already you know way ahead
of the game yeah but now everybody's so
so because news narratives seem to shift
so frequently it's led to this level of
distrust and I think it creates a Ana
mean ability to conspiracy theories in
order for the human brain to try to make
sense of the of a kit of a world that
that feels like it's in chaos
because if there's a grand unifying
theory to everything then you can sleep
at night thinking this makes sense right
there's there's so many that you could
go to I mean I for me with conspiracy
theories I always think of is it Occam's
razor
yeah yeah like the simplest explanation
is usually the one that's true so which
kind of usually eviscerates most
conspiracy theories but that demands
somebody's playing like eight
dimensional chess right like like like
it's usually not that it's usually most
things come down to human and confidence
for that callback as Greta will tell you
most things come down to human and
confidence it's not evil it's
incompetence well you've written for the
New York Times and all kinds of you know
how dare you yeah time right yeah how
dare you know talk a little bit about
that journalistic ethic and and what
goes into that well I mean there's a
level of fact checking in and major
publications where you know you're gonna
you're gonna have an editor or research
editor go back through and contact your
sources to make sure these things
happened or you prove it with taped
interviews or whatever where it becomes
clear so there's a level of
fact-checking that go on with
professional publications that don't go
on for most web-only articles so almost
almost no but that's not necessarily
always true I also write for long reads
which is web-only and they do the best
pub best fact-checking I've ever had
done but there was a time when web only
meant no fact-checking right and print
meant fact-checking I will always trust
a journalist on the ground that doesn't
mean journalists don't get things wrong
I think someone wrote I forget who it
was I wish I had this in my fingertips
or I could or it would be good
entertaining to watch me google it but
you know someone wrote
journalism is the first draft at history
so and Gladwell often says Malcolm
Gladwell often says um the later you are
the smarter you have to be which is
basically acknowledging that the first
draft of history isn't always the most
accurate
but it is a version man it is the most
accurate version at that time that's
what you're hoping to do as a reporter
when I go into something I've done many
many times most of the stuff I've done
has been reported before just not by me
so then the you're not breaking news no
I have I've had the opportunity to do
that too and it's it's liberating
because you know you don't have to you
just have to be smarter than nothing
easy but you still want to do a great
job right because you want to be you
want to make it harder for anyone to
follow you to find stuff you didn't find
but so I've done both but most of the
time I do the latter so so in that case
you know ahead what's been done and you
know where the holes are and that your
that's your role to fill it but when
you're doing it when you're when you're
covering protests on the ground or
whatever or a trump rally or something
happening in the moment there are
deadlines that happen you have to turn
in your copy right away there's someone
working on it immediately for the New
York Times specifically you turn
something in it's getting turned respect
it's a breaking story it's getting
turned around right away within hours
and it's up on the website before it's
even in the paper and it can be six
hours or three hours after you've turned
it in and the pressure to be first to
print yeah
is huge right yes inevitably is gonna
lead to errors and reporting yeah and
the whole the whole system is premised
on an ad model right it's driven by
clicks so it's inherently problematic
for that reason but it's nice to see
some of these platforms moving to
subscription model I really think that's
the future like how do we gonna get
independent you know well-reasoned
considered journalism when it's about
what is the title you know how are we
gonna get this many people to click on
this title and see these banner ads you
know it's important to say just because
journalists make mistakes sometimes they
do art often the best place to interpret
something because they're there they're
usually studying it often especially
with the New York Times they're experts
in a particular area or they've been
working on a specific desk for a period
of time so they they have the most
sources really they're the ones talking
to the most people about that very
specific thing and we have this problem
now where we don't have phase
we choose not to have faith unless we've
seen it ourselves it's like it's like a
reversal of some kind like it's almost
like the natural like blowback from what
it used to be like when I was growing up
we wanted to be iconic laughs we wanted
to be we wanted to go against the grain
I read the LA Weekly specifically
because it was a different point of view
turn to the alternative point of view
but now everyone's looking for that
alternative and and and so it's no
longer just the people on the edge of
culture looking for that now it's
everybody in culture looking for that
it's beyond just silo ization although
that's part of what we're talking about
it's it's this it's this doubt that is
so did almost everything right like we
doubt our doctors we doubt the CDC guy
we doubt our journalists we doubt we
doubt too much I used to be into being a
rebel but now we doubt too much we're
afraid to trust there's a trust deficit
and and it's incredibly destabilizing
yeah across the board for all of us when
we're all doubting on that level and we
can't agreed upon some kind of shared
ground yeah I had David Katz on the
podcast a while back he wrote an op-ed
for the New York Times at the very
beginning of the pandemic about his
perspective on kovat and whether you
agree with his perspective or not is
relevant what happened was it took he
told me it took 10 days of
back-and-forth with the editors
fact-checking changing this to make sure
that everything was like fully vetted
and by the end of that 10 10-day period
all the stats had changed again because
this thing was for good and they had to
change it again and like the elaborate
you know amount of effort that went into
just that simple op-ed that looks like
you just write it and it goes up was way
more than I think people realize like
way more than meets the eye
and it's stuff like that that gives me
you know that gives me confidence that
when I pick up a legitimate publication
like that that I'm getting something
different than I'm then I'm going to get
from a blogger with an
and yet with no editorial oversight yeah
there you go
so I think that's it for today it's good
man thanks for having feel I feel good I
mean it's always good to bat the tennis
ball back and forth
Rama safe safe social distance I think
is it I think we're making it till we
make it let's make it till we make it I
mean right now we will go slip pink
milkshakes and eat candy and make some
really important policy decisions yeah
exactly
all right well until next time my friend
probably two weeks from now thank you
for doing this with me I appreciate it
thanks for having me
listen cludes this episode of roll on
whatever we decide to title this role on
everything if you enjoyed this you can
find Adam online at Adam Skolnick you
know and all the socials you know where
to find me this is also up on youtube if
you want to watch us ping-pong back and
forth verbally what else check out the
show notes on the episode page we're
gonna link up all the stuff that we
talked about today so you can delve
deeper into whatever piqued your
interest and that's it I want to thank
everybody helped put on the show today
Jason cami yellow for audio engineering
production interstitial music Blake
Curtis for videoing today's show and
making look beautiful and all those
clips that we share around on social
media Georgia Bailey for copywriting Ali
Rogers for portraits Jessica Miranda for
graphics and theme music bye my boys
Tyler PI trapper Pyatt and Harvey Mathis
and DK sitting over there right now DK
for the important advertiser
relationships we see you back here in a
couple days with another amazing episode
I appreciate all you guys taking this
journey with me allowing me and Adam and
I to think out loud in real time and
hope you guys enjoyed it peace plants
[Music]